Speaker 1: Failed former President Donald Trump
posted an unhinged tirade to truth social.
Speaker 3: Censure.
Speaker 1: Because the Republican
National Committee had, I guess, the audacity to
make some decisions about primary debates without
checking with Donald Trump first. This is so damn
funny. New York Times reported a couple of weeks
ago. What was it? Yeah, two weeks ago. Fox News
to host first Republican presidential primary
debate. All right, no big deal. The candidates
will face off in August in Milwaukee. I mean,
think of that. The first debate is only four
months away. Of course, the Republican National
Committee has to make some decisions about that.
The article says Republican. National Committee
Chairwoman Ronna McDaniel says they will be asked
to agree to a loyalty pledge before they take the
stage. This is something we've talked about
before. Republican candidates will be asked
to sign a pledge that if they lose, they will
support whoever is the eventual nominee. We've
already dealt with that in terms of whether Trump
will go for it. So I won't delve into it again.
This is happening. I mean, it's a completely
unremarkable thing. We're going to host the very
first debate with Fox News. It will be a Fox News
Republican primary debate, said Ronna McDaniel.
Trump, who is the current frontrunner, has refused
to say whether he would support a nominee other
than himself. In a February radio appearance, he
said his support would have to depend on who the
nominee was. Okay, so it's no big deal. The RNC
is getting themselves set up for some debates.
Trump goes to troth yesterday and says, quote, I
see that everybody is talking about the Republican
Capital D debates, but nobody got my approval
or the approval of the Trump Capital C campaign
before announcing them. When you're leading by
seemingly insurmountable numbers and you have
hostile capital and networks with angry Trump
and MAGA hating anchors asking the questions,
why subject yourself to being libeled and abused?
Also, the capital s second Capital D debate is
being held at the Reagan Library, the chairman
of which is amazingly, Fred Ryan, publisher of
the Washington Post. No. So Trump seems to be
saying he will not even participate in the first
Republican primary debate of 2024. And you know
who thinks that this is a logical thing to do?
Trump propagandist Steve Bannon. Steve Bannon
appeared yesterday on the Charlie Kirk show and
said, it's all a joke. We're not having a primary.
Basically suggesting Trump should just essentially
be given the nomination. I just noticed there's
something very strange going on with my hair
and I apologize for that. Here's Steve Bannon
saying Trump should just sit out the debates.
Speaker 5: We don't have a primary and
we're not going to have a primary. And
President Trump, I think, is going to just
be audacity to go to the Reagan Library,
run by the guy that that is the Washington
Post's publisher, Fredrick Ryan. Yep. It's a
it's a it's a it's a joke.
Speaker 2: But it's not a
surprise. This is the RNC.
Speaker 5: Yeah,
it's an insult to the president. It's an insult to
the president. It's insulting maggots. Insult all
the volunteers. Full stop. No debates.
The only piercing debate is whether the
Democratic nominee is that.
Speaker 2: That's right.
Speaker 1: Okay, so let me interpret this for you.
How dare anyone subject Trump to an opportunity to
embarrass himself, which could almost certainly
only hurt him rather than help him? And to that
extent, I actually get it. I actually get it.
If DeSantis doesn't run for it, let's imagine
DeSantis doesn't run. If Sanders doesn't run,
Trump is essentially a shoo in. He's going to
be up against ones and twos. His stock will
probably rise dramatically in the polling.
The debate can only hurt him. And then if DeSantis
does run, there's a risk that the debate could
hurt him now. Again, I've said before, I don't
think that the totally uncharismatic Ron DeSantis
is going to really be able to go against Trump
in a national campaign. But could he do okay in
a single debate against Trump? Maybe. And it's
certainly possible that if the Santos is running
that it would not be particularly good for Trump
in that debate. But also, if Trump was prepared,
it could be good. But it is seen as a risk to
Trump. And how how dare anyone have the audacity
to actually have a primary election? Trump should
just be appointed the nominee is what Trump and
Charlie Kirk and Steve Bannon seem to believe.
This is I wasn't kidding when I said this is going
to be a wild and insane primary. It's already
that way. And four months from now I know it's
like it's happening so quickly. Four months from
now, when the debates start, it's going to be even
more insane. All of these clips, including
Bannon on Kirk, will be on our Instagram,
which you can find by searching for David Pakman
show on Instagram. It'll be on Tik Tok. It'll be
on Snapchat, Facebook, and of course, YouTube
at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show